president obama recently announced a
campaign to attempt to destroy the
islamic state in iraq and syria
we will degrade and ultimately destroy
isil
the american strategy is to use air
power and local allies in iraq and syria
to try to eliminate the group and push
it out of its strongholds
this plan might be able to contain isis
but it will not be able to destroy it
why not there's two big reasons the
syrian civil war is a catastrophe
in humanitarian terms it's claimed about
two hundred thousand lives it's
displaced an extraordinary number of
syrians but in political terms there are
so many different factions inside syria
with competing incentives that it's very
difficult to create an effective and
stable anti-isis coalition
isis is powerful it's defeated al-qaeda
in syria
it has defeated bashar al-assad and has
defeated moderate syrian rebel groups on
the battlefield right now
the moderate rebels which obama is going
to support are very weak and even
training
5 000 or 6 000 as his plan seems to call
for
won't be enough in order to defeat isis
a force the cia estimates between
twenty thousand and thirty one thousand
five hundred
let's move on to iraq the problem in
iraq is that there are two really large
religious groups that are competing for
control over the iraqi government
shia muslims and sunni muslims the iraqi
majority is shia
the iraqi minority is sunni the majority
the shias
have oppressed repeatedly the sunnis
after taking control of the state
from saddam hussein after the original
american invasion
that is fueling isis's power because
iraqi sunnis
flock to isis they don't trust the
government to maintain their basic
rights and they're willing to try out
isis rule
rather than the central government's
rule the us needs to turn sunni iraqis
against isis otherwise isis will have
cities to hide in
and a large supply of recruits in order
to replenish itself
since 911 the united states has not
destroyed a single major jihadi group
the reasons that they exist have to do
with politics rather than a lack of
military force to counterbalance them
alone
it's hard to imagine that the united
states will have its first success with
isis one of the strongest jihadi groups
we've ever seen
you